[Música]
vamos ahora a la revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta Buen día para usted
Hola Hola Buenos días vamos a comenzar
con los medios rusos que están
reportando las particularidades de este
día de la Victoria celebrado hoy y como
no pues enmarcado en la Guerra de
Ucrania Así es Ángela vamos a empezar
con el Prada un medio muy afiliado al
kremlin destacamos un artículo que hace
su periodista empotrado con el ejército
ruso en Ucrania Alexander cots que
destaca que lo que podría haber sido un
desfile patético visto desde el frente
al final el gobierno lo hizo bien un
desfile digno para un país que lidera
una lucha eso dice Alexander koch
recordemos que hoy se celebra el 78
aniversario de la Victoria rusa frente a
la Alemania nazi en la Segunda Guerra
Mundial y este periodista tenía miedo de
que se viera el desfile por parte de los
combatientes en el frente
de una manera irrisoria no que el
gobierno no mostrará el músculo
suficiente sin embargo un desfile con
equipos más Mo con no grandes brigadas
militares sino Cadetes de las academias
militares al final ha sido un trabajo
Digno y que además dice este periodista
tienen que dar continuidad a la labor
que hicieron sus abuelos porque dice que
si sus abuelos pudieron combatir en el
frente no tenemos derecho a
decepcionarlos Por otra parte hemos
destacado el periódico
que recoge alguna de las palabras de
Vladimir Putin en este discurso por el
día de la victoria un Putin que dijo que
quiere ver que no quiere ver un futuro
lleno de guerra si no quiere un futuro
en paz y estable y dice que cualquier
ideología de superioridad es
Sencillamente inaceptable además Putin
afirmó en este discurso que se había
desatado una guerra contra Rusia pero
que el país estaba velando por su propia
seguridad y confirmó sentirse orgulloso
de sus fuerzas armadas tanto en Rusia
como en el terreno Y por último hemos
destacado Ángela un artículo del Moscú
un medio mucho más crítico con el
gobierno de Putin que titula que Putin
que el futuro de Rusia está directamente
relacionado con su desempeño en Ucrania
un Putin que se mostró combatiente y un
en un evento que se desarrolló sin
mayores dificultades pese a estos Bueno
a estas como decirlo
cuestiones que se habían presentado la
semana pasada cuando hubo este ataque
contra el kremlin con drones no
tripulados y que Rusia acusó a Ucrania
Pues mira es una retórica como menos
contradictoria Marta y llama la atención
esta defensa de la era soviética versus
Ahora cuando retrocedió la Alemania nazi
más de mil kilómetros versus 250 metros
que digo Wagner ayer que avanzaron en
Pero bueno por supuesto estas palabras
de Putin han sido ajenas a los medios
ucranianos Así es Ángela también quería
destacar que el líder del grupo Wagner
a criticado la pompa el evento y ha
dicho que el kremlin tendría que
destinar muchas más municiones al frente
en vez de hacer este desfile militar
esto en un vídeo que se ha filtrado a
través de Telegram pero volviendo a los
medios ucranianos hemos destacado el y
ucranisca Prada que tilda a Putin de
dictador y titula que el presidente ruso
mintió deliberadamente diciendo que no
hay países enemigos para el kremlin y
que Rusia quiere ver un futuro en paz y
Libertad además destaca este artículo
del yoga las acusaciones de Putin a
occidente a quienes comparó con los
nazis haciendo un símil entre Pues el
día de la Victoria que recordemos de
esta casa Victoria sobre la Alemania
nazi además
sostiene este artículo la exhibición de
fuerza aérea que no se dio ni en Moscú
ni en otras ciudades de Rusia aduciendo
situaciones de condiciones climáticas
Aunque otros medios y otros analistas
sostienen que esto fue por cuestiones de
seguridad además sostiene artículo por
finalizar que volvió a mentir Putin
cuando dijo que los ucranianos son
Rehenes de occidente Por otra parte
hemos destacado el Kevin dependen que
dice que Putin que haga uso de la
palabra guerra
significa un cambio en lo que ha venido
haciendo todos estos meses cuando la ha
llamado siempre operación militar
especial textualmente dice que marca un
cambio respecto a la insistencia del
kremling en llamarlo operación militar
especial con fines propagandísticos y
además Una curiosidad que destaca este
artículo del kit independent es que
Ucrania celebró hasta 2015 también el
día de la Victoria pero que entonces
Petro porohenko entonces presidente del
país lo cambió por el día de la Victoria
sobre el nazismo Bueno pero cuando un
desfile militar no tiene que ver con
propaganda armamentística Marta en la
prensa gráfica de este martes también
hay varias críticas que vale la pena
revisar hay caricaturas sobre el desfile
militar el liderado por Putin que nos va
a traer si Ángela hemos tres caricaturas
vamos a empezar por el morten morland de
el periódico Times británico en el que
vemos a Vladimir Putin presidiendo el
desfile militar del 9 de mayo en el que
no hay una exhibición del músculo
militar sino que vemos a cientos de
soldados que son trasladados en camiones
al frente Por otra parte hemos destacado
dos viñetas del cartoon movement el
primero es del caricaturista Letón
zengus amarus que
retrata a Vladimir Putin con un casco
rodeado de sacos y bayas para protegerse
ante los posibles peligros de un ataque
ucraniano algo que no se ha dado en el
desfile militar de este 9 de mayo y por
otra parte destacamos al caricaturista
brasileño amorín que representa a Putin
totalmente solo en su desfile militar no
hay ni público ni militares y le vemos
sobre no un carro de combate sino sobre
una esvástica zi
igual Eso depende no Kim Jong lo
felicitó por el día de la Victoria Sí
vamos a pasar de Rusia a Reino Unido el
Washington post Marta revela que el
gobierno de sunak estaría dispuesto a
enviar misiles de largo alcance a kiev y
esto ya son otros términos en la guerra
Así es porque es una petición que ha
sido constante por parte del presidente
bolodimir zelemski y ahora sostiene el
Washington Bosch que Reino Unido estaría
o que sea enorgullecido durante todos
estos meses de liderar la ayuda militar
a Ucrania y ahora estaría presionando a
la administración biden para que el
gobierno de Washington también envíe
misiles de largo alcance a kiev todo
ello en el marco de la tan esperada
contra ofensiva ucraniana algo que a lo
que Washington se ha negado durante
meses para evitar lo que dicen sería una
escalada sin precedentes en el frente de
batalla todo esto nace del fondo
internacional para Ucrania que lidera
Reino Unido y donde a principios del mes
de mayo
Unido expresó su interés para hacerse
con misiles de largo alcance y
trasladarlos a kiev misiles que
alcanzarían a 300 kilómetros desde donde
se disparan todavía no hay una decisión
final ni sobre el tipo de armamento ni
sobre la cantidad pero parece que se
tratarían de misiles Storm Shadow que
sería un paso sustancial Pues en la
guerra en Ucrania y en el apoyo de los
aliados de aquí Ángela No claro y más
cuando esta semana Ucrania ha sugerido
que podría dar inicio la contraofensiva
de primavera pues es toda una retórica
alrededor de la guerra Marta para un
cierre muchísimo más amable y muchísimo
más emocionante vamos a hablar de los
principales ganadores del premio más
prestigioso para el periodismo si Ángela
nos referimos al premio pulitzer que
hacen honor al maestro del periodismo
Joseph pulitzer ayer Se recibieron estos
galardones unos premios que se
celebraron por primera vez en 1917 los
galardonados reciben 15.000 dólares y
además quien recibe premio al mejor
servicio público se lleva una medalla de
oro los principales galardonados en esta
edición de 2023 Fueron por una parte la
agencia social Express que ganó 12
premios Por una parte a la mejor
cobertura fotográfica y por otra parte
al mejor servicio público por su
cobertura de la guerra en Ucrania Por
otra parte el New York Times ganó al
mejor reportaje por
retratar los asesinatos de civiles
embucha destacamos también otro galardón
al Washington post que ganó por su
reportaje sobre las consecuencias de la
decisión de derogar El Rover versus
weight en Estados Unidos y por último
Los Ángeles Times se llevó el galardón a
la categoría de mejores noticias de
última hora por revelar conversaciones
de los mandatarios de la ciudad de Los
Ángeles que hacían comentarios racistas
Ángela por eso no le ha despedido por
adelantado Gracias Marta gracias Ángela